so joe biden's hit the road in a bus
with the slogan no malarkey across its
side I guess dagnabbit where are my dang
trousers was a bit too long but what a
time-travel machine it is the slogan
conjuring of a time when old men wore
fedoras smoked on trains and work
through a heart attack so is it meant to
bring back images of the good old days
which for many it isn't I mean the last
time man used malarkey as an adjective
it was probably to describe giving the
right to vote to women but maybe
adopting Biden's most obvious flaw is
the point
shuri reminds you of someone's granddad
wandering the local hardware store but
is that so bad especially when clips of
these keep surfacing and by the way you
know I sit on the stand and to get hot I
got Lana I got hairy legs that turned
that that that that that turned about
blonde in the Sun and the kids used to
come up and reach in the pool and rub my
leg down so it was trade and then watch
the hair come back up again they look at
it so I learned about roaches I learned
about kids jumping on my lap and I've
loved kids jumping on my lap Oh God
thanks for that holy crap that was from
two years ago
no idea what it means but that's Joe
every story feels like a dream retold by
a preteen in pyjamas a connection of
words excitedly released in no
particular order or any known language
he's still up in two poles yet there's a
sense he's heading straight into the
path of an orange tornado so how does he
turn this darn-tootin jalopy around
maybe he doesn't have to fact is Biden
is it really the party's nominee
impeachment is the hearings are their
answer to Trump rallies the only thing
that gives the Dems of Hope above
desperation that they might get Trump
out of office with or without Gramps
waving his cane at the kids on the lawn
so bright may seem out of time in more
ways than one but at least on tour I'll
have plenty of jaw breakers to give to
the kids even if they smell like
mothballs all right we went out of the
street said a couple producers out into
the street today mainly because it was
snowing and I wanted to make them feel
bad to find out if anybody knows what
malarkey means Joe Biden has launched a
No
larkey bus tour we want to ask what is
malarkey well I have no clue it's just a
bunch of junk I have no idea
bs that's a big word I'm not sure
everyone's would be able to understand
that one I'm no idea malarkey is
something that may or may not be true
but it's enhanced is there's a bunch of
nonsense I don't know it's a crazy
phrase that Joe Biden is using to help
him get elected it's not gonna work what
is malarkey I have no idea
monkey business brownie that's hogwash I
don't have a clue malarkey
how would you spell that Jesse how would
you grade the man on the streets needed
some movie clips in there I'm just
enjoying watching a failed presidential
campaign happen in real time because
this is what we're witnessing so I think
we just need to take a moment and enjoy
the moment because this is what a
failing presidential campaign looks like
at least he's doing it all on brand with
malarkey I mean he's known as kind of a
goofy back-slapping throwback he kind of
plagiarized the John McCain
what was that buses named straight
straight talk Express I mean he's doing
the best he can but you know when he
talks about the record player or corn
pop or clipping coupons everyone's like
wait is this guy in touch with reality
and that clip you played about kids
stroking his wet leg hair and it pulled
not only that but also this week there's
a photograph of him sucking on his
wife's finger like that thank you Kizzy
but really weird and then did you see
the picture of him trying to get the
guy's attention at the diner and the
guy's just sitting there watching the
football game no idea the VP is there so
this guy's way out of touch and you know
Trump's up on everything compared to him
well you know why I think you need to
respond to to point out that obviously
he's still a commanding lead in the
polls right no I have an issue with you
but I'm so upset because I'm a
grandfather and you were going after him
as well you know what us old folks us Oh
we're still in the game but anyway so
what so what you guys would have
prefered like horse feathers feathers or
baloney yellow tea
whenever the baloney no but I mean as I
recall having once been on John McCain
Straight Talk Express it was a hit
people reporters thought it was an
opportunity to get time with the
candidate well they understood it most
of the people there understood it yeah I
mean I just think when I listen to
especially I was listening to my man
Jesse here I think you know I think
Republicans are worried about Joe Biden
you call it a failing campaign but the
guys doing proud in a year we'll see if
the campaign he's undergone all these
attacks on the Ukraine on his son and
the airplane he's still doing good yeah
well he's not doing so well in Iowa so
he's trailing behind Pete Buddha judge
Elizabeth Warren Bernie Sanders so look
he's talking to his people young people
don't drive out the vote older people do
people who know what the term malarkey
means they're going to do the ones
voting for him and I actually think it's
a good move because if you don't know
what it means you can google it as a
young person and find out exactly what
it is that's true Biden's bus don't know
what the word means and it gets a lot of
attention yes that's good for him but
you should stop with the leg care
stories yeah creepy anymore that Dana
I'm Pro malarkey I love old things you
do I like them I kind of corny jokes Oh
to them I like yes corny jokes I think
okay so I think he could maybe he maybe
could get through Iowa or at least
through Super Tuesday even if he doesn't
win Iowa could get there maybe hit let's
say he does his vice presidential choice
would be really important right what did
John McCain try to do he went with
somebody younger
somebody episode was like a generational
change he went with Sarah Palin
something very exciting of course that
didn't end up working out for that
campaign but it did give John McCain a
boost and perhaps what Joe Biden is
thinking this is me thinking doesn't
maybe what they're thinking the
Democrats need somebody to be in a
holding pattern for 2020 because they
cannot figure out what their agreed-upon
coalition is until 2024 there the fight
between the far left and the
progressives and the moderates is not
going to get resolved in 60 days before
the Iowa vote
so perhaps Biden just calms the Seas
gets through one term while they try to
figure out what they're gonna do in 2024
interesting like a rebuilding term not
rebuilding year JW & JW s of water sir
president I could be his vice for that
yeah a united get out pretty unity
ticket